when I'm talking to a libertarian and
and I make the point that the USDA food
pyramid is not God's truth they're like
oh oh right of course it is I thank you
all for coming tonight at the Museum of
sex and evening presented by reason I'm
John Tierney and I'm here with John
Durant the caveman who is he's produced
a great book and he has a great
background he he studied evolutionary
psychology at Harvard under Steven
Pinker they came to New York and I went
into consulting and gained 20 pounds and
he started experimenting with a
different kind of diet going back to a
Paleo diet
and along the way he acquired a great
following sort of a cult following he's
got a website called hunter-gatherer
dot-com and he's just produced a
wonderful book called the the Paleo
manifesto and this book gives you in I
think three chapters the the scope of
the history of human evolution all the
way from the Paleolithic to the present
it explains why Jews are the chosen
people the the microbiology of Moses why
Jesus did not wash his hands before the
Last Supper why we don't eat cats and
and and many other things he goes into
of course what many people are
interested in the the Paleo diet and he
debunks a lot of the the dietary wisdom
about low-fat diets the things that the
establishment has been pushing lately
it's a very nice he's not a fan of
industrial food but he is not a preachy
vegan he's not someone who goes on about
sustainable farming he doesn't want us
to become hunter-gatherers or peasant
farmers and he also has a wonderful
thoughts about why gyms are so awful how
we should exercise that's a very brief
summary of it now I'll ask John to just
give us an overview of the paleo
manifesto well thank you for having me
the the here's a quick overview of the
concept a lot of the health conditions
that people suffer from too
diabetes obesity autoimmune conditions
basically are mismatched conditions and
by mismatch I mean they result from a
mismatch between our primal genes and
our primal biology and how we evolved
and the lifestyles we lead today our
diet and sedentary activity patterns or
lack of activity and and so the the
basic concept is by mimicking key
aspects of our ancestral lifestyle or
ancestral lifestyles you can prevent the
onset a lot of a lot of these chronic
health conditions so the book basically
is is three parts past present and
future a short history of humanity and
then a the present which is more
practical which covers food fasting
movement standing walking running
thermoregulation Sun and sleep and then
a third part which is short and more
speculative about where we're going
focusing more on ethics in the
environment and and the theme throughout
all of it is starting to take human
evolution seriously now why are our
libertarians drawn to the paleo concept
that that's a good question the it's
multifaceted there are a few different
answers the the first thing is that if
you look at the organic movement and the
existing food movement
it really sprang out of vegetarianism if
you look at early early the early
organic movement it's almost exclusively
vegetarian and there was a lot of
political and ideological baggage that
came along with that that point of view
and so there are a lot of people who
have been interested in optimal health
or simply just good health who have felt
excluded from the food movement because
it meant buying into all these other
beliefs so there was latent demand I
think for a point of view like this
another factor is that libertarians 10
to understand the power of spontaneous
order of how you can get very
intelligent outcomes from decentralized
solutions as in a like in an economy
that that you can have an intelligent an
emergent order and and you see the same
thing and biological evolution you have
these intricate incredibly well
coordinated organisms and life forms
that have come about over millions of
years of decentralized tinkering and
decision making and and aren't the
result of a single centralized Authority
libertarians tend to be a little bit
less religious and so are open to ideas
of evolution and then there's some other
factors like paleo folks don't shy away
from eating meat and there's there's a
masculine strain a little bit through
libertarianism and and paleo even though
these days paleo is about 50/50
male/female that's still sometimes
people will read articles in the press
and paleo will be will be portrayed as
sort of this macho eating raw meat
straight off the bone you know hardcore
CrossFit people rah rah rah and but when
you actually look at the people who are
doing it it's about 50/50 male/female
that's far more male than pretty much
any dietary approach out there because
most Dietary Approaches are about 80%
female whether you're looking at diets
or veganism and vegetarianism so it's
it's actually I think of it as an
approach for humans but relative to
other dietary approaches it's a little
bit more masculine and libertarians are
willing to think different and go
against the grain so to speak and and
and and so you certainly need to think
different to take this approach and go
against the conventional wisdom in
certain ways and then when you look at
when I'm talking to a libertarian and
and I make the point that the USDA
food pyramid is not God's truth like
over oh right of course it isn't you
know it doesn't require a lot of
persuasion to libertarians that that the
official federal guidelines on diet are
wrong so I think all of those together
combined well I'm shocked to hear that
the guidelines are wrong to me can you
tell me where the federal government and
maybe also where modern agricultural
society went wrong well the big picture
of you is that people started eating a
lot of industrial food after the
Industrial Revolution so refined sugar
refined flour hard alcohol became more
common and and and more inexpensive
Crisco and vegetable oils and things
like that and and Big Macs and Twinkies
and we know that humans are not adapted
to industrial food and you see obesity
and diabetes so everybody sort of gets
that we're not adapted to industrial
food so the logical next step is okay
well what did we eat before we ate
industrial food well most people were
farmers and farmers grow grains and they
have herds of cattle where with which
they milk for dairy and so we should go
back to that well that's correct insofar
as avoiding industrial foods is probably
in avoiding a heavily industrial diet is
probably a good thing but it's not
correct in thinking that that's the
optimal human diet
we've only been eating agricultural
foods for at most about 10,000 years so
so that's one area where we went wrong
but then also you just look in the
nineteen in the 1970s George McGovern
chaired a Senate committee that
established dietary goals for the United
States and that's when a lot of the anti
fat orthodoxy got put into place
officially and when you started to see a
greater push by
government to eat less fat and fat
usually meant fewer animal products and
eat more carbohydrate which usually
meant grains practically speaking we
corn and legumes like soy so so in our
political history that's really when you
start to see the shift to what I believe
to be incorrect dietary guys a good
scientists at the time we're saying we
don't really have any evidence for the
benefits of a loaf I mean there were a
few activists sort of in the American
Medical Association and kind of you know
consumer activists pushing this but
there were people saying we don't really
you know no no that it's true that
health science in human beings is very
difficult no matter what you believe
it's unethical to run properly
controlled tile trials and dietary
interventions because unless you're
dealing with the prison population what
how are you going to ensure that people
are actually eating what they say
they're gonna eat a lot of the studies
that have been done on nutrition have
been done based on self-reported
questionnaires of what people remember
having eaten over the past year so how
no matter what the outcome how are you
supposed to get good scientific results
from something like that and the answer
is you can't
but people have treated some of the
early nutrition science as sort of as
the gold standard even though it was
often very poorly conducted pretty much
no matter what the outcome was now why
don't you just tell us what you know
very briefly what's in the Paleo diet
and also speaking of scientific evidence
is there much you know data for the
Paleo diet so the the brief overview
everybody agrees that too many processed
foods ie industrial foods aren't good
for you
where paleo differs from the
conventional wisdom is primarily around
grains legumes and grain products wheat
corn soy and then around dairy the way
that most people eat paleo is they tend
be more strict about grains and grain
products particularly wheat and soy a
legume and then there's more flexibility
and differentiation and how people treat
dairy a lot of people particularly of
European ancestry who are lactose
tolerant do eat some traditional full
fat dairy so that that's the quick
overview of of it and then in terms of
the science you know the the research
cycle for studying these things tends to
be five to seven years from when a topic
starts to gain an interest - when
studies get people start applying for
grants studies get funded research gets
done so really in the next two to three
years we'll see a lot more studies
coming out and you know we'll start to
see what the science says there there
have been studies that have been done
where you take indigenous populations
you return them to their traditional
diet all sorts of health problems clear
up there are other small trials that
have happened that are very promising
but more needs to be done now there's a
conventional wisdom that the
vegetarianism has been shown to be
healthier than than eating meat the
vegetarians do better what's the what
are the facts on that if if you take
sort of an ecologist perspective or an
anthropologist perspective on
vegetarianism it's sort of a funny
concept it's like humans are omnivores
we've been omnivores since before we
were human and and not just plants and
animals but insects and fungi and all
sorts of different things particularly
since the advent of cooking about a
million years ago we've eaten pretty
much all sorts of things that that we
could get our hands on and to think that
somehow the optimal human diet just sort
of magically there's this clean line
between things that have a face and that
make us feel sad for them are unhealthy
and things that don't it's it's pretty
ridiculous and and if you're talking to
evolutionary biologists veganism just
gets laughed out of the room it's it's
not even a hypothesis that that's taken
seriously
a lot of the
a lot of the evidence for for
vegetarianism and basically any dietary
intervention is if you remove industrial
foods white flour refined sugar
vegetable oils from people's diet
they're going to get healthier no matter
what whether it's Atkins or
vegetarianism or any of that when you
look at a lot of the studies that have
shown positive effects for vegetarianism
have been conducted on the seventh day
adventists which is a religious group a
close-knit religious group that is very
different in many aspects from other
people and when you actually compare
seventh-day adventists to Mormons who
are who are more similar than people in
the general population but Mormons will
still eat meat
Mormons perform better than the general
population at large so it's it's it's
not at all clear that removing meat from
the diet is is actually the driver of
better health outcomes among seventh-day
Adventists well I'm sure we're gonna
have more questions on diet but before
we open it up I just wanted to ask you
about why are Jews the chosen people
here so I have a chapter in my book my
book even though it's called the paleo
manifesto it's not just about the
Paleolithic and there has been
adaptation to new ways of living and new
foods since the Paleolithic both
cultural and genetic and I have a
chapter called Moses the microbiologist
about cultural adaptation to living in
cities which was the most dramatic
change since the Agricultural Revolution
it would diet was important but
primarily important insofar as it
allowed larger populations to congregate
in cities and the greatest health
challenge in cities was infectious
disease and it's around this time when
you start to see early religions like
Judaism emerge that plays a huge
emphasis on hygiene and cultural
practices like hand washing and bathing
and avoiding bodily fluids and harsh
sexual sexual codes
I mean and
and these a lot of these practices in
retrospect were effective ways of
avoiding contamination or infectious
disease which was the number one source
of mortality so I have this chapter
where I propose what I believe is a
novel hypothesis for the emergence of
monotheism which is basically that if
you have a community of people say the
Jewish people
Zoroastrianism zoroastrians would work -
they're very similar if you have a group
of people that follow a scientifically
sound hygiene code and it is enforced
throughout almost the entire population
then that group of people will suffer a
lower infectious disease burden things
like protecting their water supply
hand-washing things like that things
that are in the Bible in the Torah and
so it will look like this group of
people is favored by God because they're
dying less people don't know that germs
are killing people and so and and so
they attribute all these deaths to God
and divine retribution and and then if
sinning is defined as unhygenic
practices which is totally
uncontroversial very well established
then then the people who sinned by
getting tattoos by participating in
sacred prostitution cannibalism they
will be more likely to get infected and
die and it will look like they're being
struck down by God and if you have false
gods all around this hygienic scientific
god then these quote false gods will
actually in and say these false gods are
promulgating unhygenic practices like
tattooing or sacred prostitution they
will actually be functionally
incompatible with a quote one true God
that is as hygienic practices so you
could you could actually get a dynamic
where a basically this this very
abstract the Jewish God is knowing known
for being abstract and faceless and
depersonalized
and very rule-bound well that actually
describes science fairly well and so you
could actually have a scientifically
sound hygiene code that was unitary of
one mind that came in conflict with all
these superstitious false gods around so
that's that's actually ten years from
now I think is going to be the part of
the book that I think will still be most
unique even there is nothing to do with
the Paleo diet
well how did Jesus get away with not
washing his hands well so this is this
is interesting so Jesus one of his big
points of contention with the Pharisees
was over whether he should wash his
hands before eating and he said this is
silly you don't have to why do you have
to put your hands together and run water
over them before you eat and all the
Pharisees said they freaked out and they
said you have to wash your hands before
you eat are you kidding that's gross
it's in three of the Gospels it's in
three of the Gospels it's on it's re
words I think well it's you know in in
Hebrew I I don't know the translation
and and and and so basically Jesus took
fundamentally Jewish moral beliefs but
basically jettisoned all the purity code
and the hygiene code circumcision
hand-washing food kosher law all these
things that made the Jewish people made
it costly to be Jewish and it was hard
to get converts but you get rid of that
purity code and you just keep the moral
teachings and if you do it during the
Roman Empire when people are there's a
civic and secular religion of public
baths aqueducts so clean water and
public baths aqueducts and and just
generally relatively cleaner technology
then you can get rid of all the costly
hygienic practices keep the moral code
and it spreads really quickly but
eventually you say that the Christians
paid the price with the Black Death yes
yeah well it's it's right there and
Krish in in in the tour it's right there
in the holy book that if you so so
basically the the Jewish people one of
the definitive moments and the identity
and formation of sort of the people of
Israel the Jewish people is the flight
from Egypt I'm not speaking about the
historical accuracy of of that event but
the story is there's a group of people
that is mysteriously resistant to
pandemics and plagues and soon
afterwards when they're supposedly in
Sinai in the desert their God commands
all the Jewish priests to wash their
hands a lot hand washing is the most
effective and simplest form of Hygiene
ever discovered it's Nobel worthy so so
and and then you have all of these you
you suddenly get all of these rules that
many of them are scientifically sound so
I in and right there it says if you stop
following these rules then I'll strike
you down with all sorts of nasty
diseases itches and boils and insects
and infestations and also all sorts of
all sorts of nasty things so it was
right there in the holy book that what
you should do to avoid plague and during
the Black Plague you said the Jewish
populations actually did suffer less is
that right well there were widespread
rumors of them and Jews throughout
Europe or scapegoated and Christians
said that they that they had poisoned
wells which they did not do the evidence
for Jews poisoning wells was that a lot
of the evidence was that a lot of Jewish
populations would cover their well which
is actually a perfectly prudent thing to
do if if you're protecting your water
supply and and if vermin rats most
insects are unclean in kosher law so
there was generally to anyone who is
observant they would have been staying
away for
these species so if you Christians at
the time said that Jews were dying less
from from the plague scapegoated them
tortured prominent Jews extracted force
confessions
said that they were behind it but it
could have simply been that Jewish folks
were washing their hands a one last
question you talked a lot about
industrial food and you don't like it
and but you also don't they're not in
Michael Pollan or anyone's camp on that
how do you see you know what should we
be eating what kind of food how should
we grow our food and in what should we
do what's I mean is it important to be
organic in the whole sustainable food
movement this is an area where some of
my libertarian beliefs have been
challenged because growing up I was a
little bit of a libertarian fanboy and
companies could do no wrong or I might
talk about negative things that
different corporations would do but I
would often at the end of the day come
to defend them and then I realize in
terms of my own health that okay if
Kraft corporation or Nestle if Nestle is
making infant formula for a hundreds you
know for a hundred years and the science
is overwhelming that breastfeeding is
healthier for infants and mothers than
than infant formula well just because
they release a new product and are
making money off of it doesn't mean that
it's necessarily good for you
so some of my i'm not just because
something is new and reformulated
doesn't mean necessarily that it's
better at the same time vegetarianism
and veganism is so ideologically driven
that that's not attractive either so
what i try to do in my own life and it's
difficult is it's just a i try to take
the best of the old with the best of the
new my view of human nature
is informed by millions of years of
evolution and what came before but it
doesn't mean I automatically reject
something that's new new tech now I love
and
new technology I love living here in New
York City I love the culture and
technology so it just means that you
have to be discriminating about what old
things you hold on to what old
principles and what what new things you
adopt now what do you think about the
movement of sustainable food and local
you know local origin
well there's not there's not enough land
right now for everybody to just adopt
organic farming there's not enough land
for everybody to just become eat paleo
throughout the entire world but I don't
I don't think that's really the point
here's where I think vegetarianism has
gone off the rails the point of people
eating differently is not that everybody
in the world has to eat that way it's
that you're empowering entrepreneurs to
experiment and to innovate so if if half
a million people are a million people
eat say say say a million people eat
vegetarian and they want to change the
food system what they're essentially
engaging in is a boycott on meat the
problem is boycotts are only effective
if you have a large number of people
involved in them or if it damages the
reputation of a firm so it has to be a
widely held view within the population
vegetarianism is maybe 2% 1/2 percent of
the population and most people eat and
enjoy meat so it's it's actually an
economic boycott is in a very
ineffective way to change the food
system and to encourage innovation you
have all these entrepreneurial farmers
who are experimenting with new methods
of permaculture farming integrating
technology - you know remotely know when
the best time to yeah rotate different
crops are trying new things and that's
great and and it's far more important to
support entrepreneurs that are doing
things that you like to help them get
off the ground get the first dollar of
revenue their first dollar of profit
than it is to withhold money from the
big guys who are doing something that
you don't like so I view a lot of this
paleo stuff
as voluntary consumers saying this is
how I eat I feel good when I live this
way and I'm going to contribute money to
entrepreneurs that provide something
that I like and and so there I don't
there's nothing like hippie dippie about
that I just want I just want more people
to more more entrepreneurs to produce
the types of products that I actually
like and make my make me healthy and
make me feel good as we open up the
questions now thank you
it's me again first I just want to say
that was a really really good exchange
john tierney your questions were perfect
and it's just great framing and john
durant your responses were terrific and
and your Paleo diet as a way of
perceiving culture and history and
evolution and so forth and so it's just
great so thank you
now you're gonna lower the bill yeah
well you're an idiot actually actually
John I'm going to save the questions on
evolutionary perspective for others
before I do ask a question that I do
have I just want to mention everyone
since you John Durant mentioned the
don't eat something with a face there is
a debate tomorrow night some of you know
the intelligence squared debate series
and the resolution is don't eat anything
with a face it's a debate on veganism
they're very well done debates if you
like to its kind of sold out but there
are ways of getting in if it if you're
interested google it or ask me so I'm
going to ask a question about culture in
the modern day but given my Geographic
if not cultural heritage what do the
French think of the Paleo diet well the
the first of all when it comes to being
pro fat the French love fat there's a
thing called the French paradox which is
the French eat so much saturated fat
and they have relatively low rates of
cardiovascular disease well that's
that's in line with with a lot of what
folks in paleo have also been saying the
French eat nose to tail
I eat nose to tail the French follow
traditional recipes and cuisines well I
think that's good too where there's a
where there's some disagreement is
primarily around grains and grain
products I would say that if somebody is
having if somebody actually has a health
problem that they're trying to address
it could be a digestive problem an
autoimmune disorder weight issues mental
issues trouble getting pregnant then
then I would finger grains and grain
products as as the first thing if we're
not talking about an industrial diet and
I'm quite sure that there are French
people with irritable bowel syndrome who
could benefit from experimenting with
removing grains from their diet and
seeing it seen if it goes away it seems
like it sometimes doesn't it I had two
questions one my father and a lot of the
older men I know dramatically reduced
their meat intake just they get to an
age and they just start eating this meat
is is there I guess it's hard to
consider that you know most of our
ancestors wouldn't have been alive in
their 70s and 80s but do you think
there's a physical reason for that it
seems to be very widespread amongst his
generation and secondly we didn't really
touch on the physical activity aspect of
it very much but do I take it you would
approve of my treadmill desk of what my
treadmill desk
oh yes yes I use a standing desk not a
treadmill desk but I think it's great to
be on your feet as much as possible
they've there have been a bunch of
studies coming out showing that even
independent of whether you workout
during the day or during the week in for
an hour so it's beneficial to be
standing and
and just being sedentary for most of the
day has has a lot of harmful effects and
forget all that I just feel more
confident and assertive whether I'm
talking on the phone or doing work when
I'm standing up in terms of eating meat
there's an impression of paleo folks eat
being carnivores I'm not a carnivore I'm
an omnivore I didn't actually increase
my meat intake when I went paleo I
basically switched out wheat corn and
soy for a lot of vegetables and changed
improved the quality of the food that I
was eating you know older men aren't
tend not to be as muscular so so that
could be part of it people do have
different protein requirements and meet
requirements you know I I don't I don't
have like an exact amount that I think
is the same for all people so I I'm not
sure I can answer it more than that yes
what are your you elaborate on the
connection between the Paleo diet and
mental health and my second question
what are paleo people's ideas towards
paleo libertarians that is people that
are yeah it doesn't it's not as it
sounds um people that are socially
conservative yet you know endorse the
libertarian ideals are people more
liberal there are people more like kind
of new agey libertarian are people more
kind of like socially conservative
libertarian so what was your first part
again so the first part was what's the
relationship between the Paleo diet and
mental health alright so if in terms of
mental health if sometimes it's most of
the time it's a lot easier to look at
any particular health issue in non-human
animals rather than humans because
everybody has preconceived notions about
what's normal for humans you don't
really see what could be termed mental
health problems in in non-human animals
until you get into zoos in zoos you see
a lot of mental health problems what are
called stereotype ease things like
pacing back and forth a lot of people
see polar bears do this
other types of repetitive movements
lethargy not eating things that might
appear like depression if we could talk
to the animal so I do tend to think that
a lot of mental health issues are
mismatched conditions the certain amount
temporary temporary depression or
feeling sad temporary negative emotions
a lot of those are perfectly normal and
they help motivate different types of
behavior in life that's totally normal
chronic long-term mental health
conditions I think nearly all of those
are mismatched conditions in terms of
what types of Libertarians I mean you
definitely get some crunchy cons some
folks like that but libertarians are
optimizers and you just get a lot of
people who who don't just want to feel
okay they want to feel great they want
to feel strong and so they're looking
for that leg up to so you get it and you
get a lot of non libertarians I mean you
get tons of non libertarians I mean
trust me if if somebody has an
autoimmune condition or Crohn's disease
something like that and they remove soy
and it goes away it doesn't matter what
your political beliefs are you're going
to keep doing it thank you my question
is along the lines of how did the Jews
get it right because I mean I think back
and it was common belief that you know
using leeches was the right way to treat
was believed to go off in a lot of other
of medical directions and yet as you
point out in this instance some people
got it right how did that happen
it's really hard to say I you you
certainly do have a dynamic basically a
spontaneous order dynamic we're
profitable beneficial customs and
practices can emerge without any
coordination without any one person
knowing it or realizing it if if
somebody just sort of ran
this washes their hands more than other
people and that practice delivers a huge
survival and reproductive benefit you
know it can spread throughout a
population just like a genetic mutation
can even if people adopt it for the
wrong reason so the first step is
realizing there didn't necessarily have
to be a person a single person that
understood the germ theory of disease
things can emerge spices the practice of
spicing our foods is an antimicrobial
properties there might not have been a
person ever who said oh let's put salt
and pepper and cumin and all these other
things in food because it causes it not
to spoil it can just emerge but base it
but basically if you look at when the
Torah was formalized it was soon after
the Babylonian captivity
which is five hundred and something BC
and there are a lot of either Babylonian
or Persian rules that are that are in
the in the Torah so what I think is
likely is that Zahra
Zoroastrianism probably preceded Judaism
and a lot of these rules emerged they're
more formalized into a coherent
framework and then imposed upon the
Jewish people while they were slaves and
then sent back to Israel but I think a
lot of these ideas so I think a lot of
them emerge but then were formalized
when the Jewish people were slaves in
Babylon we could talk about that all
night you just this question I'm not
sure though having been brought up
Jewish hearing this stuff help but kind
of sit in my seat but the one thing you
know much about is diet which is
interesting considering the fact that
paleo is a diet so if you know I don't
know too much about paleo other than my
friends suddenly saying they're not
eating bread and there
a lot of meat you know very vain and not
being able to figure out why the heck
I'm hearing about this had a reason
event first which is but it's
fascinating so my question for you is if
there is some link between what their
chosen you know Judaism it's so nice
when people talk about us like that when
Judy is at what might be linked to our
habits like our washing our hands but
are there any links to our diet because
there's a large part of what makes up
Jewish tradition is the diet in a large
part of what frankly I rejected was the
diet and nothing that you've said yet
about the Paleo diet seems to link so is
there a link or is it just
well the everybody focuses when it comes
to kosher law to kashrut everybody
focuses on pork and shellfish and I
think that emphasis is misplaced I think
that's more of a product of we notice
that more today in modern times but if
you look at kashrut it gets a few big
things right which are don't touch
corpses don't eat anything that died of
its own accord stay away from vermin and
stay away from nearly all insects
aside from locusts crickets and
grasshoppers which don't feed on
corporate courses they feed on crops and
plants and and are less likely to be a
vector for disease so if you just look
and then many of the other species I'm
not the first one to point this out by
the way I'm synthesizing this many other
species that are banned are at the top
of the food chain
vultures lions or for pod animals things
that devour corpses and farmers farmers
know these sorts of things that if
cattle dies what species comes along and
devours it and in Zoroastrianism the way
they would get rid of human bodies human
corpses they take it to a mountaintop
and allow it to be devoured by wild
birds and dogs so we know people at the
time we're doing this we're using these
species for corpse disposal so if you
forget about pork and shellfish and you
just focus on corpses and animals that
died of their own accord vermin
sex and protecting species that devour
corpses that's really all you need and
the rest you know maybe maybe there's
some just like there's genetic drift
maybe there's cultural drift or other
reasons for things and that's fine yeah
don't don't you know don't boil a kid in
its mother's milk I don't know I don't
know the answer to that but but I think
if you get corpses vermin insects right
and then you protect the species that
eat corpses vermin and insects your most
of the way there right trichinosis is a
common reason there's a reason yeah yeah
I mean we can we could people have been
arguing about that for millennia but
also not I mean not killing cats and
animals that devour rodents right so so
you might think that's an exotic concept
to avoid certain species because they
provide a service of corpse disposal but
how many people in this room have ever
eaten cat before Julian
alright well cat became taboo originally
in Egypt because they self domesticated
and ate vermin and it was very
beneficial to have cats around to eat
all the vermin they provided a useful
service it as I say in the book cook
cats don't catch mice it's not enough to
just cook the cat the cat has to be
alive to do what it needs to do so if
the fact that none of us eat cat in this
room is a is is a way in which we are
all not eating a top level carnivore for
ecological reasons it's hard to disagree
with anything you said and it's
fascinating by the way and I think
everybody in our socio-economic class
would agree with you however I want to
play devil's advocate please do all of
the things you described in the Paleo
diet are
not really scalable and industrial foods
are and they're cheap as a result and
they feed millions so I don't know that
there's a question in here but but this
is so first of all I don't think
everybody in the world is going to
immediately adopt a paleo diet and I
think that's okay some people enjoy
eating bread some people are fine eating
however they like to eat that's okay
so first one benefit is simply that it
encourages innovation among farmers
entrepreneurs to find new methods that
that do scale better and that do have
higher yields without necessarily using
traditional or not traditional but
industrial methods there's a great TED
talk by Allan savory about how cattle
can take desert areas and return them to
grasslands so re-entering the food
system can be beneficial hunting is
carnot carnivores and predators are
important part of natural ecosystems we
need hunters to be shooting deer and to
be eating deer and that's healthy so I
think paleo can play a different role in
the food system then say veganism or
vegetarianism when you look at a lot of
the solutions for veganism it to
resource use in veganism and
vegetarianism a lot of it is just eat
less meat okay well if everybody stopped
eating meat that's a one time reduction
in resource use but people are still
eating industrially grown crops and
soybeans and things like that okay so
there's a third you know 30% last serve
50% less use of of resources I'm not
sure that that's a complete game-changer
what I think is more likely is people
are going to become wealthier when
people become wealthier they're going to
eat more meat we're also seeing a slow
of population growth so that's that's
putting some limits on that and I think
we're gonna see a lot of change in
biotechnology that is probably going
end up being the types of breakthroughs
that we're looking for stuff with algae
fish farming things like that well how
about just growing meat in the
laboratory I mean do you have it when
you talk about industrial food do you
object to producing I understand what
grains fit into this and you think about
that our bodies are not suited to them
so well but it's just you know producing
a lot of meat efficiently either you
grow it in the lab or you find new ways
to do it does that trouble you or does
it as soon as we start growing meat in a
lab all of the liberal hipsters will
switch from being vegetarians to only
eating meat because all the plebeians
will be eating the you know the the
lab-grown stuff the I guess what I
wonder that if you use it use industrial
techniques are basically just modern
modern agricultural efficiency and in
the book you say that I'm not you know
urged every wonder at a return to
traditional farming because you know
we'd all be poor but I I don't know
where the answer is and and I actually
wish more authors and thinkers would say
that what I do know is that there's
absolutely a role in healthy ecosystems
for hunters and we need hunters there's
apps I actually think that vegetarians
and vegans are right and that we can
extend the moral circle a little bit and
and there are problematic ethical issues
with factory farming so I think I
actually think they do play play a role
the excesses of breeding I don't think
there's a problem with a cow that
specializes in milk production I do
think there's a problem if you're
breeding chickens that can't even stand
and tip over because the breasts are so
large and are basically in some form of
pain for for most of their lives I at a
certain point if we're wealthy enough I
prioritize human welfare first but at a
certain point in wealthy society I would
I would rather pay a little bit more
but let me give a different reason
actually for improving improving
conditions that's very selfish a lot of
people focus on altruistic regions
completely selfish reason for changing
the factory farm system is antibiotic
resistant strains of bacteria we are
breeding biological weapons that are
going to come back to haunt us I mean
are the the antibiotics that we depend
on for our entire monacle medical system
and technology are gradually becoming
obsolete because we're using them on
cattle to make the cattle fatter faster
and so all we have to do in a lot of
these situations is give them a little
bit more space a little bit more clean
water a little bit more outdoor time and
you can actually cut back on a lot of
the antibiotics because you have more
hygienic conditions and farmers
shouldn't be able to use this is a very
libertarian thing unliberated thing but
when farmers simply use antibiotics to
fatten up their cattle faster it puts
everybody else in society at danger
because those those antibiotic resistant
strains of bacteria are then dangerous
to us when we go into the hospital when
somebody has pneumonia when some you
know when some child is trying to use
antibiotics so I think that's a I think
that's a very good selfish reason to to
change the system I have a question it's
Julian I found fabulous talk very
interesting discussion
you've said a lot of things which I
think a proponent of regulation might
agree with and they might extend what
you've said to say well in that case
hey we should regulate the consumption
of grains we should regulate the
consumption of sugar
what what is what what is your answer
see those proponents of regulation so
what particularly when it comes to what
people should eat anybody who has looked
at the history of USDA regulations and
federal government regulations of what
people should eat it is a history filled
with misinformation and bad ideas and so
before we rush headlong into another
point of view even if it's paleo even
it's my point of view I've got a little
more humility and say okay we don't
really know the answer here let's let's
just stop subsidizing certain ways of
eating
that's a middle ground that everyone can
agree on stop subsidizing the production
of corn and wheat and soy start there
and and and see what happens so that
when it comes to an abaya antibiotic
resistant strains of bacteria infectious
disease is a network phenomenon it by
its nature very well-studied it requires
coordination among almost the entire
population to address it when you look
at vaccines when you look at antibiotic
resistance public health measures so
that is probably the area one of the
areas where I'm least libertarian and I
think there's a good argument made for
coordinated activity by a population so
we can we can fight about that
afterwards but I will throw that out
there all right
from over here and then we'll go back
over here to the lady in front and then
the fellow behind me okay
you have emphasized I think that we eat
too much grain because and that's a bad
thing because genetically until we
discovered agriculture or invented
agriculture whatever the term is we
didn't need its best oh five or ten
thousand years we have developed on to
digest milk
why don't you think why wouldn't a
similar sort of process have occurred
right so haven't we adapted to
agricultural foods somewhat we clearly
lactose tolerance evolved and evolved
very quickly in multiple populations
around the world over the last five to
seven thousand years the the the so
first of all just because something's
new doesn't mean it's bad so we can come
across novel foods you know the first
the first hominin that was able to eat
meat found a nutritious nutrient-dense
source of energy and and nutrients you
know the first the first hominin who
somehow came across honey found a huge
store of energy here's the thing about
grains in particular when I think about
grains I actually think about seeds as a
category and buy seeds I mean grains
legumes nuts and seeds the reproductive
organ of the plant plants can't run away
from predators so their evolutionary
strategy is to either use shells
typically or shells or casings or
chemicals chemical warfare to keep away
hungry herbivores and insects and and
and and and so for that reason you tend
to see a huge amount of chemical
diversity in the plant kingdom they're
the source of our
the source of our poisons they can be
really good they can be really bad it
just depends which plant how you prepare
it and how much you eat of it when it
comes to seeds those tend to be the
source of nutrients them but the most
dense source of nutrients in the plant
it's the reproductive organ it's the
next generation but for that reason it
also tends to be the most toxic portion
of the plant or the the part of the the
plant that is protected the most so you
see a lot of fruit seeds or poisonous
apple seeds have trace amounts of trace
to us amounts of cyanide in them wild
almonds have cyanide in them a lot of
different fruit seeds have cyanide like
compounds in them and there are a lot of
pasture legumes that cause digestive
problems or fertility problems in a
sheep and cattle because that's in the
evolutionary interest of those plants
they don't want to be digested by the
animals that come along so the reason
why my predisposition in paleo is
against a heavily grain based diet is
because these these plants are loaded
with different naturally occurring
toxins and poisons whose purpose it is
whose purpose purpose evolutionary
purpose is to screw up our digestive
system or to screw up our reproductive
system so that we don't eat them so I
actually tend to be fairly Pro dairy but
more anti grain when it comes to novel
foods and that's the basic reason why
that's that's the big-picture view we
could get into like the biochemistry of
specific grains and legumes if we wanted
to sorry what are your feelings about
fasting oh I think fasting is fabulous
I'll try to be as short as possible and
then I know you had a question and then
we've got to wrap up but when people are
often there's all sorts of conflicting
advice on everything in diet including
eating frequency should I be snacking
all day should I have three meals a day
two meals what should I do
well with every species a good idea is
to look at its eating frequency in the
wild
gorillas are herbivores they eat almost
all day long carnivores are more
sporadic they eat like lions ate every
two to three days two to four days in
the wild and so when it comes to fasting
I consider fasting a form of eating
frequency it's a question about how
often should I eat so the first point is
one hundred gathers do not eat as
regularly or as often or as much as most
people do today three square meals a day
so I think the correct direction is
clear which is we should have more
periods of hunger in our life when it
comes to the benefits of fasting you see
these fascinating traditions emerge in
religions all around the world including
Judaism around the same time and one of
the benefits of fasting is fighting
chronic infections we all start living
in cities infectious disease proliferate
and suddenly you get all these religious
traditions that are saying okay you need
to have one day a month or an entire
month where you don't eat for 24 hours
or don't eat for 12 hours or 14 hours
and fasting is a way of basically
cutting off the cutting off the reserves
and the supplies of pathogens that are
infecting you so I there are a lot of
other benefits of fasting but I think
that's probably why it emerged and can
be very very healthy animals across the
animal kingdom will lose their appetite
when they're sick or infected as you can
think of fasting as sort of a pushing
that strategy a little bit further and
more purposefully to say okay appetite
loss helps fight infection
fasting same thing that might have been
a little wandering I think the wine is
getting to me last question Susan
basic question basic question good the
Paleo diet is it no grains corn soy is
it certain types is it no sugar not just
refined I just wanted to understand
better the
rulz and also what's wrong with refined
there's a great book that I can
recommend that has all the detail you'd
love it's called the paleo manifesto and
so my my basic approach everybody's a
little bit different
my basic approach is to say and other
people's approaches is to take a month
take three weeks a couple months and
remove all grains from your diet and
then after that period you see how you
feel you see if you've seen improvements
and then you incrementally add in
different foods and you may find a lot
of people find that rice they don't have
any problems with rice particularly
white rice white rice is carbohydrate
many more people find that wheat and
gluten grains are more problematic for
them so at that point you can determine
for yourself what causing terrible
diarrhea or cause making their
autoimmune conditions worse rheumatoid
arthritis my sister-in-law's mother
removed grains from her diet and the
arthritis that it had been bothering her
for ten years basically went away and
she went from not being able to sort of
go for a walk for a mile to being able
to walk five or six miles and not have
it be an issue so you need to I can give
you some guidelines paleo is a great
starting point it doesn't have to be
everybody's ending point if you have a
health condition you're trying to
address use it as a template as a
starting point to eliminate a bunch of
foods from your diet and then you have
to take charge and be responsible and
add in different foods and see how you
feel and you can craft your own diet you
can trademark it you can name it that's
right you can be up here so so I I guess
I'll leave people with that use it you
can use it as an excellent starting
point and then people can end up can end
up in a lot of different places
depending
how they feel and what's important to
them and meaningful of them and healthy
for them Thank You Jones very much for
sharing the paleo manifesto with us has
been great thank you all for coming and
better pass everything thank you